tonight by the way Elon Musk will be on
Tucker Carlson they've released some
previews of that and uh he started
talking about what it is like to pursue
and expose the truth
the degree to which various government
agencies had effectively had full access
to everything that was going on on
Twitter uh blew my mind I was not aware
of that would that include people's DMS
uh yes
okay so obviously a lot more is going to
come out of this for those of you that
are not on Twitter you may not know the
DM is the direct message that's supposed
to be private right so if I follow
somebody and they follow me I can
communicate them you can message them
back and forth in essence like sending a
private email to somebody we are now
finding out it's not just that they were
Shadow Banning people it's not that they
were suspending people and blowing up
accounts and all of that stuff and and
all the Litany of other things that
we're still finding out there's probably
way more that we don't know and
everything else we're also finding out
that they could read your private
messages which should not come as a
surprise to anybody because as you may
remember during the height of the hunter
Biden laptop Fiasco they disabled your
ability to even share the link to the
New York Post story within your private
DMS so pursue and expose the truth good
on you Elon Musk
foreign
[Music]